hello and welcome to the shiki science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about a recent nature publication
that has come up from the david sinclair
lab whereby they show that neurons in
the eyes of mice can be reprogrammed to
a more youthful state
in which they reacquire the ability to
regenerate and restore fission
so in this video we'll take a look at
this data and discuss how
cellular reprogramming may be able to
refer different hallmarks of aging by
refirsting
or reprogramming in this case epigenetic
marks
and so we'll go into some detail about
these three programming factors
and discuss potential mechanisms as to
how they might be acting in a cell to be
able to mediate this reversal of
epigenetic marks
so i first learnt about this study when
i read david sinclair's book lifespan
which is where we shall begin with this
video and so if you haven't read his
book or watched my amazing summary video
on it
then you first need to understand that
david explains the aging process
by using claude shannon's mathematical
theory of communication
whereby david states that aging is
simply loss of information
and so he considers this a universal
mechanism to understand the aging
process
that kind of can be considered on top of
all of the individual different
hallmarks of aging
and so if aging is loss of information
what is this information
well there are two ways that information
can be transmitted
there's digital and there's analog a key
difference between them is that analog
is continuous whilst digital information
is discrete
and so the problem this raises for
analog information is that it can
accumulate
noise and so how does this relate to
information within our own bodies
well david makes the point that we have
both analog and digital information
within ourselves
our genetic code being the digital
information and the epigenetic code
being the analog
information within our cells and so
epigenetics refers to marks
literally on top of the genetic code
that consists of either dna methylation
marks or a variety of other marks that
can be added to
proteins associated with dna and they
can alter which genes are expressed
within a cell and how
dna is compacted within the nucleus
another way of thinking about it
is to use the analogy of a dvd whereby
the genetic code is like the information
in the dvd
that encodes the film whilst the analog
information
would be on the surface of the dvd and
the surface can get scratched
and that scratching that noise
accumulation in the analog information
can impact the reading of the dvd so in
the case of a cell
the accumulation of noise within the
epigenetic marks
impacts the reading of the genetic code
and david suggests that that is a key
component
that could potentially explain the aging
process and so if aging is simply loss
of information
then to be able to prevent or to even
reverse aging
the key question is how can we recover
that lost information
and that's when the analogy to claude
shannon's mathematical theory of
communication comes in handy
so in shannon's theory he describes a
correction system
whereby there's an observer that can
record the original data
before the signal is lost there is then
the original correction data
and then there's a correcting device
that can restore the original signal
and circumvent the accumulation of noise
within the signal
so to quote david sinclair in lifespan
to end ageing as we know it
we need to find three more things that
shannon knew were essential for a signal
to be restored
even if it is obscured by noise so the
key point that david is trying to make
is that if we can identify the
biological components
that make up these three correction
device
components then that gives us a better
insight into how we
can restore the loss of information that
occurs during aging
and so the big question is what are
these biological parts
now the reason i went into so much
detail here is that we'll come back to
this model
at the end of the video plus i think
it's just a useful way
of being able to understand the aging
process as it provides a simple
framework to explain
what is quite a complicated topic so
going back to epigenetics
more evidence supporting the role of
epigenetic changes
during the aging process comes from many
studies now that have calibrated
so-called molecular clocks that can
actually measure biological age
but what we want to be able to do here
is actually be able to alter these marks
and restore it to a more youthful state
i.e being able to find the biological
correcting device
and as stated in lifespan david says i
believe we may have finally found the
biological correcting device
so what is it well it looks like the
answer may come from
a landmark study that was done in 2006
by the japanese stem cell researcher
shinya yamanaka who identified four
different genes
that could reprogram somatic cells to
become pluripotent stem cells
in other words taking a cell that's
already been differentiated
which basically means a cell that is
specialized to do a particular role
for example skin cells are very much
different to liver cells
which are also very different to neurons
when you're in your brain
and convert them back to so-called
pluripotent stem cells
and as suggested by the name pluripotent
refers to the potency the potential of
a cell to become multiple blurry
different cell types so these four
different genes
now referred to as the four yamanaka
factors
are oct4 sucks to klf4
and mick or oskm and all of them are
transcription factors
so they are proteins that can regulate
the expression of different genes within
a cell
and it's also been found that the
process that can reprogram
these somatic cells back to pluripotent
stem cells
involves erasing the cellular identity
and resetting the dna methylation age
now this sounds great
fantastic it's exactly what we want you
know get rid of those
epigenetic marks that are causing all
this noise going back to that
nice clean original state however going
back to pluripotent stem cells
may be a step too far because
pluripotent stem cells like to replicate
a lot and so what's been seen is that
expressing
all four factors in mice can often
induce so-called teratomas
teratomas is a pretty grisly tumors that
consist
of several types of tissue including
hair muscle and bone
so this isn't something that you want
nonetheless
in a 2016 study conducted by researchers
at the institute for research in
biomedicine in barcelona
and at the salk institute for biological
studies in san diego
they expressed these four factors in a
premature
aging mouse breed and they found that
not only did the
mice remained young compared to their
untreated siblings
but they also lived 40 longer
nonetheless
this only worked when they expressed the
yamanaka factors
for just two days a week throughout the
entire lifespan
when they expressed it for longer the
mice died and so this is when we come
back to the david sinclair lab
where he explains in lifespan that one
day in 2016
one of his graduate students juan
chenglou came into his office saying
that he was close to quitting
whilst trying to reverse the age of
cells without turning them into tumor
cells
and as a final effort they decided to
leave out the cmic
gene that was likely the cause of the
teratomas given that mick is a common
gene associated with tumor development
and so that left them were just the
three genes oct4
sox2 and klf4 and when they infected
these genes into both
young and also old mice they found that
after 10 to 18 months of continuous
expression of
these three genes they never saw an
increase in tumor incidence or any
negative effects on overall health
due to the expression of these genes
suggesting that as was previously
thought
without mick just the three gene seems
relatively safe to be expressed into the
mice
but instead of waiting for another year
to see if the mice lived longer
with these three genes being expressed
yuan cheng suggested he used
a mouse's optic nerve as a way to test
age reversal and rejuvenation
david was skeptical at first but then
they agreed that you might as well
go big or go home and the reason that he
was skeptical
is because in mammals one of the first
systems to lose regenerative potential
is the central nervous system
and this includes the optic nerves and
the nerves of the spinal cord
and they've been shown to never grow
back as the capacity to regenerate
is lost within a few days after birth so
they initially started with young mice
and they delivered to the three genes
into the retina of the mice
they then performed an optic nerve crush
injury study
whereby they damaged the cells and then
they analyzed the optic nerves
two weeks later with or without the
genes being expressed
as you can see in this figure here when
they actually induced the expression of
these genes
remarkably they saw regeneration and
sprouting of these
axon fibers extending around five
millimeters
when these genes weren't expressed they
didn't see any regenerative or survival
effects
so as they hypothesized they thought
that changes within the epigenetic marks
could be the key mechanism behind this
regenerative potential
so interestingly when they assess the
dna methylation age
of these retinal cells they found that
after injury
only the cells that were also expressing
these three genes
oct4 sox2 and klf4 showed a reduction
in the dna methylation age compared to
cells that weren't expressing these
genes
which showed an increase in their dna
methylation age after injury
so maybe unsurprisingly then they went
on to show that
active dna demethylation is necessary
but not sufficient by itself to be able
to induce this regenerative potential
following expression of these three
genes and they did this by knocking down
the expression of dna d-methylases
tet1 or tet2 but so far they've only
used quite young mice
later on they were interested in seeing
whether or not osk induction
could restore the dna methylation age of
older mice
in addition to being able to restore
youthful vision
and a younger transcriptome signature so
to test this they treated
3 and 11 month-old mice with the three
genes
and induced expression for four weeks
they then
analyzed the optomotor response and they
also looked at the transcriptomics
as you can see in this figure here older
mice that were induced to express the
three genes
showed an improvement in their optimus
activity and if you look at these heat
maps which shows the rna sequencing
results
whereby they looked at the different
genes being expressed they found that
the profile of the old mice treated with
expression of these three genes
more closely matched the young
expression profile to be a bit more
specific
there was around 464 genes that were
altered during aging
and around 90 of these genes were
restored to the youthful levels
by the osk treatment so in other words
it looks like this osk
treatment restored vision in regular old
mice
and this is by no means just a throwaway
sentence
because if adult cells in the body can
be reprogrammed
to regain a youthful epigenome it
suggests that the information to be
young cannot all be lost
suggesting that there are biological
equivalents to claude shannon's
correction device
and also suggesting that these yamanaka
factors
these three genes are able to somehow
access this correction data
to mediate the resetting of the
epigenome that's seen in these
experiments and the working model that
the authors hypothesize
is that in the presence of these three
factors a complex is able to recruit
these tech enzymes these dna
d-methylases
to specific sites in the genome and
induce
active demethylation however they also
state that there's likely to be other
factors involved in this process as well
since the tet enzymes were necessary but
not sufficient to induce the
reprogramming
so more workers definitely still needed
to identify these factors
along with understanding how cells
encode and store this useful epigenetic
information
however i suppose another interesting
question is this study was done in mice
what potential does this have for humans
well
whilst in the study they did also show
that axon regeneration occurs in human
neurons and culture
there are a lot of questions that still
need to be addressed before further
experiments on humans
for example can all of the components be
delivered safely to the right cells
will it eventually cause cancer can the
genes be expressed for only a short time
period and then switched off again to
let the cells rest
will it work better in some tissues than
other and could it be given to
middle-aged people
before they become sick the same way we
take statins to keep cholesterol in
check to prevent heart disease
nonetheless according to this article
harvard have licensed the technology to
boston company
life biosciences which sinclair says is
carrying out pre-clinical safety
assessments with a few to developing it
for use and people
so all in all i think there's great
promise and potential for cellular
reprogramming
but i think it will take some time to
properly assess how safe it is
to use and the impacts of long-term
expression
in particular due to the risks
associated with tumor genesis
nonetheless i found this study eye
opening and
i will definitely be keeping my eyes
peeled for any further developments
in this area of cellular reprogramming
so i'm sure other people probably have
thoughts so
please leave any ideas uh discussion
points in the comments below and i'll
try and reply to as many as possible
and as a reminder using the discount
code shiki you can get 10 off
of products at donutage.org which is
where i get my nmn from
anyway as always i hope you've learned
something in this video
and thanks for listening